the angels will send dylan bundy to the
mound this afternoon bundy is oh and
five and i think those numbers are very
surprising to the guys that are in the
athletics lineup because what he did
against last year he was very very good
tony kemp for the first time this season
will lead off broke his bat bounces it
right to walsh and he will solo to the
bag and that will be the first out so
one quick out unassisted play ramon
laureano will be the next batter here's
the next delivery bounced on the third
base side rindone has it throws to first
gets the throw there in time two up two
away
kid lowry will be the batter this is
tapped softly first base side fair ball
fielded right near the bag by walsh and
three up in three down
as bundy throws only
nine pitches in the inning and gets
three ground ball out sean manaya trying
to rebound from his last start and a lot
of off-speed pitches against the astros
and tucker got him took him deep and
the lefties just seemed to do quite well
against him in oakland where they did
not do that well against him in houston
the angels with the unique look with
justin upton leading off for the first
time ever in his major league career and
swings and misses at a bad ball to
change up in the dirt mania gets a break
at number one that'll bring up the
veteran phil gosling outside corner ring
him up strike three call two away and
that'll bring up anthony rindon and he
walked him so rindon gets on two out
walk juan lagarus will be the next
batter off speed bounce toward first up
with it olson he's going to tag lagarus
in the baseline and the inning is over
and after one final game of the series
the a's and the angels no score olson
leads off for the a's against dylan
bundy top of the second with the seven
home runs in the series the a's now lead
the american league at home runs
thrilled to right way back in the corner
and no doubt about that and olson has
hit another home run and matt's homert
in back-to-back games and the athletics
take a one-nothing lead and for the a's
that's the eighth home run they have hit
in this series and seth brown coming up
is swung on in that's a rocket to right
if it's fair it's gone right down the
line and gone and seth brown is really
getting high and it's three nothing a's
and the home run story continues for
these over this weekend
in southern california so the angels
have their first hit iglesias
singles to left center and jared walsh
is coming up the ground ball and spirit
chat with a back and throw bare hand
flip to first by pinder is not in time
but he is going to force at second base
nothing conventional about that
fielder's choice chapman threw it kind
of sidearm backhand and pinder
bare-handed him i saw the ball did it go
behind him or over them oh it hits her
hits the back of the chair which would
have given him another base yeah here's
taylor ward hitting a ground ball
speared by pinder goes to second camp
goes to first that's a double play to
end the inning and that's a six four
three and then quickly the bottom of the
second comes to an end tony kemp begins
the top of the third inning with his
first triple of 20-21 and that'll bring
jed lowry to the plate hit right through
the second baseman fletcher and that'll
easily waltz home tony campus 4-0
oakland so here is olson 3-2
swung on and slapped the other way
that's a base sit for olson
and that will move lowry up to second
base so matt after a great start
two for two today as the a's continue to
threaten it may be a short day for dylan
bundy that's going to be it for dylan
bundy his issues on the mound continue
he was hoping to get his first win of
the season today in his ninth start but
it is not going to happen new pitcher is
aaron sledgers and that'll keep the line
moving it's going to fill the bases for
chad pinder a chance for the ace to
really extend things here on the angels
already ahead four to nothing full count
pitch it's chased and missed and he got
him on a sinker struck him out slaggers
does a good job they will end up leaving
the bases loaded four-nothing a's and
shamania back to work against the a
batter drew butera veteran backup
catcher swung on and missed and got on
strikes is butera third k for mania and
that's a swing and a miss that's the
second time he's paid it's four overall
now for mania allowed long single to
start the fourth heading for the a's and
here comes luis pereira hey there's a
line drive that's a base hit to left
field and that's the first big league
hit for luis pereira get that baseball
first in the big leagues for luis
barrera slashing it the other way claps
the hands indeed
get the kid the baseball
as barrera gets his first big league hit
and he's got a smile from ear to ear
moving the runners to
second and third one away here comes
laureano as the a's look to build on
their four-nothing advantage swinging a
miss chased a high fastball right there
seashell throwing that one by loriano
and that will be the second out kid
lowry will be the next batter next
delivery that's a chase and a miss
seashell comes in and strikes out
loriano and lowry back to back to end
the inning now the angels making some
noise with rudders at first and third
and one out and here comes their big
power threat and that's jared walsh
first [ __ ] hit hard diving play by
kemp he throws to second and they get
the out at second base arundo's coming
to score but a terrific play by tony
kemp diving to his left now the angels
making some noise and the a's lead is
only three as the halos have two on and
two out and rendon is coming up all of a
sudden this becomes a little bit of a
scary situation tying run at the plate
swung on bounce left side taking it
short pender has it fires to first for
the out and mania works out of it jared
walsh hit the ball hard twice a day
nothing to show for it yet lefty's just
three of 17 against birch this year has
not allowed a long ball to a righty or
lefty until now calling it yeah all
right
walsh it's a high fly ball
deep right field goal did you
dig yourself the angels get a little
closer trailing it four to two look at
that play liking it too now there's two
on and nobody out so here's the pinch
hitter jose rojas he grounds it on the
right side skips off the glove but kemp
ball goes into right field fletcher come
on down
it's four to three and now the bases are
loaded oh connie is going to be the
pinch hitter you hear the buzz in the
crowd this is the moment in the absence
of mike trout the basic reason to come
out to see a game is to see ohtani oh
tony
a screamer to right and he ties it up
could he hit that ball hard
and now iglesias is due
to the right side the halos have the
lead
iglesias gets it done all the way back
to onto out here's murphy it's down by a
run and swung on a comebacker off of
watson recovers he turns he throws it
first on a hop and it gets away from the
first baseman walsh one run is scored as
olson has scored it's a tie ball game
how do you like that angels have him at
the corners and justin upton who's had a
pretty good ball game as the angel
leadoff man today he'll bat with runners
at first and third one out this is hit
high in the air not that deep in left
field pinder is waiting he'll make the
catch so a sac fly by upton and the
angels have regained the lead it's now
6-5
hayes are down to their final out in
this spa game better bring up lowry
he'll be the ace last shot the 2-2
got him and the halo shines bright
tonight in angel's victory they come
from behind